[Music]
all right so let's we want to get and
get some tickets long because I think we
don't things we could do with it so
again get related two thousand five
minutes for politics if the goal is for
it to be fast and quick and must protect
against data corruption data corruption
being losing data or having issues
because of because the way that it saves
the data where the things are being
rewritten etc it had overcome from those
things you have with other with the CDF
so it is designed for frequent batch
branching so it is designed for the sole
purpose of you being able to kind of
take create all these different branches
and merge it back together fairly easily
right you can just get in to emulate TV
after submerging servers ie
of different clients and subversion can
connect to get if you want it to all
right so um with that being said let's
go ahead and let's go working some of
this stuff okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm create
another directory called yet and then
I'm a clear where you make at the top so
this is my get directly message and just
so we let me take it and move it up one
level okay so I'm a city into my gig
directory and there's nothing there okay
now the first thing I'm gonna do in this
term I'm going to config get to work
with my uh my github or my git server
username right so in this case my it's
it's read and then maybe my get to pick
so now so what the idea is that forget
in order to connect to the repos and
after had the right names and email
address so that one every time you make
is attributed to you and then to so it
can use it for kind of username password
authentication all right so here I'm
going I'm unclear this all right so I'm
in my get director there's nothing there
but I'm going to do a get you knit and
this is what this does is that anytime I
think that I understand is going to
initialize the directory and what that
does
really it checks it up for gift
operations all right that that LS dash L
this that command shows a hidden files
hidden files or any directory that
begins with a dot okay so hard doing LS
I wouldn't see anything but when I won
that Delos that's al I see my hidden
directories so if I were to go into that
hidden directory I would see principally
this thing that's kind of set up
similarly like that other repo right I
get my branches I got to config and if I
were to even going to the pig I see that
I had some other stuff that's in there
right but nonetheless we're not getting
to all that those things because it can
get pretty deep really fast and I'm
going to clear it so we're all checking
along alright now that I've initialized
the directory let's go ahead and let's
create a couple of files so I'm gonna do
it echoed in court and all I'm doing is
creating just files right it doesn't
really matter what files they are in
just I'm just creating files and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to add this
just let me get a SP and add I may add
everything that I've created to my local
repo and that's that dot means get add
every dirty that's here right everything
that's here so when I do that and I do a
git status I see that all those things
my test fit by Java file with added now
oh you say oh I forgot to include this
well let me go ahead and create another
thing and I will name this my text file
dot txt and then I might add it again
and then you will notice it just simply
add it to the list
okay now from here what I'm going to do
is I'm going to commit this I'm going to
get commit dash M my first conviction
like that and what that does it takes it
and commit it to my local repo not to
the dis not to the server not anywhere
just here locally right and then if I
give it get lost
- step oh yeah
family law okay I can see the commit
that I made and the commit number and
what was committed okay
now if I were to RM remove the test that
job and then get a get Ad like that and
then get status you see that it deleted
some file again if I didn't ever commit
like that and then come back and
[Music]
when you're logged man that is I see
that there's one that we're adding the
file but I see that here in my other
condition made by this person at this
time it was removed okay
all right any question about what I did
so far
nope all right so what I'm going to do
here is I'm lead up there and I don't I
don't think it's going to disconnect
this I'm gonna go here I'm gonna go to
github.com I'm gonna create a new one
and let's call it a new repo just bet
right I'll make a public repo and I'm
gonna create the repo all right so look
it gives you some nice cool easy stuff
that already had here okay which is
really nice because you're going to try
to do these things and you know you like
well how does that work and this kind of
looks complete step-by-step so um so so
what I have is a a a an existing repo
okay so what I have to do is just get
the load hat right here and organ this
edge of simply a pointer to my local
repo to this repo so I'm gonna come here
and we're just gonna paste that right
there oh then I'm paste correctly
like that okay and that's going to add
that there no now watch this now when I
go to do this thing's let me give an
error so now I'm ready to push my
commits to this repo I didn't okay good
so here it is I'm there
now watch this sync
there it is I push for my machine over
to my new repo but you see here I don't
have any branches laughs so um some of
the things I could do is like this I
could do git branch and I'll say my
branch all right it could be just as
easy as that and when I do a git status
I still see I'm on the master branch
okay but what I do I'll get a check out
which is kind of Swiss is a thing for uh
for switching branches I'm gonna do with
Lila brass yeah my branch like this and
then if I do a git status I see that I'm
on my branch so if I show it bottom of
my branch if I do a create fee like this
so if I do a see echo test
my files like that that test right and
then I have to LS she that I had that
new file there Domino's get add the
module git commit dash M hello
right and so from there I can see that I
owe that status I'll do always do that
status through oh sorry there I see that
it had it that file right here that's
the latest commit all right and then
ah
but here's why so in this it didn't
create the branch so already coming here
and say my branch like that I created
the branch
all right you work origin this will
happily you all split
sometimes you went to something issued
by a tables that again
various okay all right and so now in
your branch you see that this you had
that put in your branch you have this
two files okay all right with that being
said I think we've hit our first hour
and but a most part list let's um let's
buckle then get to a few slides to go to
slides and then I think we'll be done
okay so here's the workload just so you
can have some to point back to so the
goal is almost always it's got to do
first is that you're going to you're
going to do a get you're going to do a
clone call followed by some URL and you
get that URL from get okay once you
clone it and you make some changes
hopefully you're going typically you do
a a get pool
and that pools any additional changes
from that from that particular of the
pilot or e2 you get checkout often is
used to switch branches but then
hopefully from there you do get ad
followed by get committed followed by
good push
and that's normally the way that it
works
together okay pool edit and commit push
all right cool edit your files add two
files committed and push this last
bullet right here
that's the winner okay all right so we
talk to we are working a lot of this
okay so there are GUI front-ends for
working through stuff just so you can
see it even for Mac there's a github
desktop and from here pretty much
everything I could do on the command
line I can do here as well like a pull
request I can sync things up I can
compare changes all kinds of things
right and you can even have any for
Windows as well right so just nice way
to kind of you know for those who did
kind of like this theme you do it that
way as well
we talked about now this is probably
important to for your yes there is
github but if you want a something you
can install locally you can download get
lab and check that up for your your own
service and get laughs provides more
popular features because who the
audience is more business-oriented okay
hey what's become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe the simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing
click here